und ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt
eine vereinbarte debatte zum
arbeitsprogramm 2021 der europäischen
kommission in ihrem jährlichen
arbeitsprogramm liegt die kommission die
maßnahmen der kommenden zwölf monate
fest neue initiativen überarbeitung von
vorschriften etc
nicht enthalten sind die laufenden
aufgaben wie die durchsetzung bereits
bestehenden eu rechts das aktuelle
arbeitsprogramm ist natürlich eng
verknüpft mit dem eu-haushalt 20 21 27
denen sie heute morgen hier schon mal
hatten und dem chor ohne hilfspaket next
generation eu 750 milliarden schwere das
herzstück
ja und laut arbeitsprogramm 20 21 plant
die kommission für dieses jahr 86
initiativen und heiko maas wird jetzt
das ein oder andere sicherlich dazu hier
vorstellen können vielen dank herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
im moment blicken viele mit viel frust
nach brüssel
das hat was mit der beschaffung von
impfstoffen zu tun und ja die
beschaffung der impfstoffe hätte besser
laufen können so etwas einzugestehen ist
auch eine unumgängliche voraussetzung um
aus fehlern für die zukunft zu lernen
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
bin genauso fest davon überzeugt eine
gemeinsame europäische beschaffung der
impfstoffe war der einzig vernünftige
weg denn was wäre die alternative
gewesen ein europäisches wettrennen
jeder gegen jeden um den knappen
impfstoff einige wenige durch geimpfte
länder mitten in einem
krisengeschüttelten kontinent das ist
eigentlich und das will ich auch gar
nicht mehr in einem solidarischen europa
vorstellen
es hätte die europäische union zerrissen
davon bin ich fest überzeugt
vor allem liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
da aber das tägliche krisenmanagement
mit dem wir uns ja alle beschäftigen
nicht den blick auf das verstellen die
europa dauerhaft aus dieser krise
gestärkt hervorgehen kann und das wird
uns nur gelingen wenn wir den im letzten
jahr eingeschlagenen solidarischen kurs
fortsetzen werden
das arbeitsprogramm der europäischen
kommission für das jahr 2021 bringt
unser ziel auf den punkt eine gerechte
ökologische und digitale gesellschaft
kleine reförmchen werden dafür nicht
mehr ausreichen
wir brauchen viel mehr die kraft zu
einer echten transformation und der
schlüssel um diesem wandel in einklang
mit unseren werten und interessen zu
gestalten
der liegt letztlich vor allen dingen in
einem solidarischen und in einem
souveränen in europa während des letzten
halben jahres unsere ratspräsidentschaft
haben wir dafür wichtige pflöcke
einschlagen können
und jetzt arbeiten wir gemeinsam mit
unseren trio partner an portugal und
slowenien daran dass die dinge auch
umgesetzt werden die einigung auf den
finanzrahmen und das corona aufbau
instrument mit seinen 750 milliarden
euro war nichts anderes als ein
historischer akt europäischer
solidarität
und jetzt kommt es darauf an die
entsprechenden mittel schnell verfügbar
zu machen und deshalb müssen in allen
mitgliedstaaten die hierfür nötigen
beschlüsse gefasst werden und die pläne
in brüssel und nach brüssel endlich auf
den weg gebracht werden
der neue rechtsstaats mechanismus und
das neue menschenrechts sanktionsregime
stärken die europäische
wertegemeinschaft und das ist gerade bei
all den diskussionen die wir in der
europäischen union etwa mit blick auf
rechtsstaatlichkeit hatten jetzt nötiger
denn die und meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren um einige konkrete beispiele
zu erwähnen insbesondere aus einem
bereich der ein sehr zukunftsträchtiger
ist nämlich der digitalisierung wir
haben mit der datenschutz grund
verordnung vieles auf den weg gebracht
und wir werden das auch jetzt mit dem
digital service act und dem deutschen
markt weiter führen und das sind die
arbeiten die zur zeit in brüssel unter
hochdruck dort fortgeführt werden und
wir haben in unserer ratspräsidentschaft
dafür eine vernünftige basis gelegt und
gepaart mit ambitionierten investitionen
liegt darin dann das fundament für ein
digital souveränes europa für einen
menschen zentriertes digitales modell
das sich gegen rain markt gesteuerte
oder repressive modelle die wir auch auf
der welt sehen können auch durchsetzen
können mit dem instrument schuhe haben
wir europa sozialer und gerechter
gemacht
denn liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
nicht banken und großkonzerne sondern
menschen stehen im mittelpunkt der
krisenbewältigung und es ist auch gut
dass wir diesen paradigmenwechsel beim
sozialgipfel im mai in portugal
fortführen werden
meine damen und herren mit unserem
ehrgeizigen klimaziele hat europa auch
rechtzeitig vor der kopf 26 in glasgow
wieder eine globale vorreiterrolle im
kampf gegen den klimawandel eingenommen
und ich bin froh das wird uns dabei
helfen dem globalen anspruch dieses
themas gerecht zu werden dass wir jetzt
endlich auch wieder die amerikaner mit
an bord haben und auch außenpolitisch
hat die europäische union trotz vieler
probleme vieler schwierigkeiten dennoch
an gewicht und auch angesicht gewonnen
nie zuvor waren wir uns so einig dass
die herausforderung
chinas oder russlands gemeinsam
angegangen werden müssen
unsere reaktion auf das vorgehen in
hongkong oder zuletzt im fall einer
weile zeigt das wie ich finde auch sehr
deutlich und sehr konkret und mit der
europäischen den weg werden wir auch
weitergehen mit an mit blick auf andere
konflikte mit denen wir es international
zu tun haben und mit der europäischen
friedens fazilität oder dem zentrum für
ziviles krisenmanagement haben wir auch
instrumente geschaffen die uns in krisen
handlungsfähiger und auch
transatlantisch zu einem stärkeren
partner machen und das alles meine damen
und herren das alles werden wir weiter
vorantreiben mit einem neuen sogenannten
strategischen kompass denen wir uns
dieses jahr gemeinsam in europa geben
wollen und darin werden wir auch europas
bekenntnis zum multilateralismus
verankern
und weil wir dabei nicht an worten
sondern an taten gemessen werden haben
die europäische union und ihre
mitgliedstaaten den kuhweg 19 tools
assekurata und die gerechte impfstoff
verteilung mittlerweile mit über drei
milliarden euro unterstützen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen tägliches
krisen management und strategisches
handeln
um europa dauerhaft aus der krise zu
führen und besser vorzubereiten auf die
krisen die sich in zukunft noch ergeben
werden in den nächsten monaten muss
beides weiter hand in hand gehen und bei
der antwort auf die frage wie europa in
10 oder 20 jahren aussehen soll
sondern wir vor allem die bürgerinnen
und bürger europas hören und deshalb
hoffen wir dass mai endlich die
konferenz zur zukunft europas auch
beginnen wird
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das alles
sind mammut aufgaben die auf uns warten
aber eine solidarische und eine
souveräne europäische union ist dafür
gut gewappnet herzlichen dank der
bundesaußenminister
als erster redner der vereinbarten in
die debatte arbeitsprogramm 20 21 der eu
kommission
norbert kleinwächter er ist mitglied im
ausschuss für angelegenheiten der
europäischen union und mitglied in der
afg fraktion hat jetzt als nächster
redner hier das wort im parlament
da wird der präsident sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen die kommission
beschreibt das ja offen was sie möchte
vor nicht ganz einem jahr hat diese
kommission ihr amt mit der agenda
angetreten den größten umbau europas
seit mehr als einer generation
voranzutreiben
für diese agenda wurde sie gewählt ja
das wird der wahl kann man auch anders
sehen gewählt haben die wähler
eigentlich was völlig anderes als was
sie dann bekommen haben angela merkel
und emanuel makro haben ursula von der
leyen ins amt gehievt oder hat das ep
das akzeptiert das ist die wahrheit und
deswegen tragen
auch emanuel marken und angela merkel
eine entscheidende mitverantwortung an
diesem papier an diesem arbeitsprogramm
der europäischen kommission und das ist
völlig gegen die menschen gerichtet wie
es auch gegen die menschen gerichtet ist
zeigt auch der kommentar zu corona
kuroda die pandemie wird tatsächlich
begrüßt weil es zitat den wandel stark
beschleunigt hat und daher
paradoxerweise auch mit großen chancen
verbunden ist also sehr geehrte
bürgerinnen und bürger sie verlieren
ihre arbeit
sie verlieren ihre wohnung vielleicht
ihre selbstständigkeit ein
familienmitglied einen geliebten
verwandten und das ist eine chance ihr
leid ist der boden auf dem ursula von
der leyen ihre politik auf macht meine
damen und herren genau das ist ekelhaft
dieses arbeitsprogramm ist ein manifest
ein manifest der niedertracht
und dieses system wandelt ihr gegen die
menschen gerichtet ist er hat auch
überhaupt keinen respekt vor der
nationalen souveränität erkennt auch den
gedanken der freiheit nicht oder etwa
der demokratie der begriff der freiheit
kommt gar nicht vor
ja weder weder als begriff noch
irgendwie gedanklich freiheit existiert
nicht in diesem gesetz gedankenkonstrukt
und demokratie wird komplett umdefiniert
plötzlich zu einer union der gleichheit
also wir haben keine gleichheit mehr vor
den gesetzen postuliert wird sondern es
wird auch eine faktische gleichheit
hingearbeitet und wir was dagegen hat
der wird gleich im gleichen abschnitt
als redner bezeichnet hassrede alle
dimensionen davon werden ja zukünftig
als straftat von europäischer dimension
ausgewiesen
ja meine damen und herren und selbst wer
liebevoll irrt der ist dann wohl ein
desinformations super sprayer und weil
desinformation auch bekämpft wird was
das dann eben auch mit dieser person
sehr demokratisch vor dieser eu ist
wirklich absolut nichts sicher weder die
industrie noch die familien die
industrie wird das 55 prozent
reduktionsziel co2 eindeutig nicht
überstehen das ist kein
wachstumsprogramm sondern ein wachstums
vernichtungs programm und zu den
familien selbst vor den familien macht
die eu-kommission nicht halt da gibt es
für sich eine kinder garantie wo man
sich die frage stellt was hat die
eu-kommission da eigentlich zu suchen
es geht um einen angriff auf die
familien vielleicht sind ja die eltern
einer politisch ungewollten meinung dann
kann man da was dagegen tun
die eu kommission fürchtet außerdem im
bereich der migration mit herum bis
migrations und asylpolitik system schon
mit dem illegale migration massenhaft
gefördert werden soll
jetzt nimmt sie sich die legale
migration vor möchte also definieren wir
auch legal zu uns kommen kann und dafür
ein talent und kompetenzpaket erarbeiten
das orientiert sie sicherlich einen
außergewöhnlichen fähigkeiten von ursula
von der leyen
meine damen und herren und wer davon
eine abweichende meinung hat der wird
eben letztendlich als festredner
bezeichnet auch besser verfolgbare mit
einer europäischen digitalen identität
der europäische raum für
gesundheitsdaten ermöglicht es selbst
andere informationen noch einzuholen und
die richtlinie für vermögens
schöpfung stellen verrät nur ansatzweise
worum es da vielleicht geht wir kennen
das aus internationalen straftaten das
dann vermögen einbehalten werden kann
aber wenn hass reise schon eine
internationale straftat wird dann wissen
wir in welche richtung dieser zug
überhaupt hin fährt mein opa sagte zu
mir immer als ich so irgendwie sieben
oder acht jahre war werdet ihr sehen die
eu das wird der europäische untergang
und ich wollte ihn wirklich nicht
glauben ich glaubte an die europäischen
freiheit man die kulturelle
zusammenarbeit und all das aber diese
europäische union ist der verlust
jeglichen wohlstands jeglicher freiheit
und jeglicher demokratie und dafür ist
der preis zu hoch
wir brauchen jetzt ein engagement gegen
diese eu kommission die sogenannte das
sogenannte europäische parlament muss
die kommission aus dem amt entfernen
sonst entfernt die kommission alle
unsere werte und unseren wohlstand aus
der europäischen union haben sie vielen
dank
[Applaus]
der nächste redner für die cdu csu
fraktion ist der kollege florian hahn
[Applaus]
jaja präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen eher kleinwächter sie
machen es einem wirklich schwer sich
nicht auf ihre rede zu beziehen
ich weiß nicht was da wir uns mit ihnen
gemacht hat aber ich sage ihnen mal 1
wenn sie sie haben das arbeitsprogramm
der eu kommission als gegen die menschen
gerichtet bezeichnet und sie haben es
als manifest der niedertracht bezeichnet
gleichzeitig wollen sie mit den opfern
der pandemie und gleichzeitig wiederum
verbreiten sie beispielsweise über ihre
facebook accounts querdenker thesen mit
beispielsweise dem satz masken bleiben
sinnlos und gefährlich ich sage ihnen
eins der einzige der hier wirklich
niederträchtig ist ja solche politik
macht sind sie und nicht die europäische
kommission
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die eu
stehen auch in diesem jahr vor großen
herausforderungen vielleicht sogar vor
den größten seit ihrer gründung und seit
dem ersten januar 2021 ist das
vereinigte königreich mit der ausnahme
nordirlands nicht mehr teil des eu
binnenmarkts die folgen werden für die
menschen in der eu und für die
wirtschaft von tag zu tag hörbare
gleichzeitig die korona pandemie hält
europa auch in diesem jahr im würgegriff
wir alle leiden in erheblichem maße
darunter und zum club gibt es unter der
deutschen unter der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft im zweiten halbjahr
letzten jahres ist es gott sei dank
gelungen einige dicke brocken abzuräumen
ich denke da an den neuen mehrjährigen
finanzrahmen ich denke da an den corona
wiederaufbau von next generation eu aber
auch an das handels- und
kooperationsabkommen mit dem vereinigten
königreich das ebenfalls kurz vor
jahresende geeinigt werden konnte und wo
stünden wir heute wenn diese einigungen
auf europäischer ebene gescheitert
werden deshalb danke ich der
bundesregierung unter der führung
unserer bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
noch einmal ausdrücklich für das was sie
während der ratspräsidentschaft
geleistet hat liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen da die eu unter der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft handlungsfähigkeit
bewiesen hat kann sie sich nun verstärkt
auch anderen prioritäten widmen
zum beispiel wie sie sich geopolitisch
besser aufstellen kann
das internationale umfeld hat sich durch
den amtsantritt des neuen us präsidenten
joe biden in entsprechend verbessert
nutzen wir dieses momentum um das
transatlantische band wieder zu stärken
das gilt beispielsweise in der
handelspolitik für die die europäische
kommission letzte woche neustadt eine
neue strategie vorgestellt hat werben
wir bei unseren amerikanischen freunden
zum beispiel dafür die längst
überfällige reform der
welthandelsorganisation gemeinsam
anzustoßen und was das arbeitsprogramm
der kommission für das jahr 20 21 angeht
möchte ich mich auf einige anmerkungen
beschränkten die mir wichtig erscheinen
erstens auch in ihren neuen
arbeitsprogramm fokussiert sich die eu
kommission auf den klimawandel und die
digitale transformation sowie auf die
damit einhergehenden gesellschaftlichen
großen herausforderungen hin zum
zentralen thema klimaschutz kündigt sie
das so genannte fit für 55 paket an mit
dem das neue ehrgeizigen eu klimaziel
für zwanzig dreißig angepackt werden
sollen
das ist im ansatz auch richtig da der
klimawandel trotz corona langfristig die
größte herausforderung für europa und
die menschheit an sich darstellt
aber die eu politik muss angesichts der
pandemie folgen jetzt ganz besonders
darauf achten dass die rahmenbedingungen
so gestellt werden und gestaltet werden
dass die internationale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der unternehmen
gestärkt wird wirtschaftliches wachstum
möglich bleibt und beschäftigung
gesichert wird und das gilt ganz
besonders für unseren mittelstand
denn unsere mit unser mittelstand wird
auch das rückgrat für die erholung aus
der krise sein und deswegen müssen wir
ganz besonders darauf achten
zweitens ein thema das sich die aktuelle
portugiesischer ratspräsidentschaft
auf die fahne geschrieben hat ist das
soziale europa und zur umsetzung der
europäischen säule sozialer rechte will
die eu kommission einen aktionsplan
vorlegen der anfang mai auf einem
hochrangigen sozialgipfel import
verabschiedet werden soll
ohne frage hat die europäische
sozialpolitik ihre verdienste und
berechtigung zum beispiel im bereich der
sozialen koordinierung und natürlich ist
und bleibt konvergenz der sozialen
bedingungen innerhalb der europäischen
union
gerade vor dem hintergrund der
unterschiedlichen starken auswirkungen
der korona pandemie auf die
mitgliedstaaten starten ein wichtiges
ziel
aber das will ich auch sagen auch gerade
wegen der korona pandemie die unsere
wirtschaft tief getroffen hat rate ich
dazu es mit vermeintlichen sozialen
wohltaten nicht zu übertreiben
der nachhaltige soziale verbesserungen
wird es nur mit wirtschaftlichem
wachstum und einer verbesserten
wettbewerbsfähigkeit geben und in diesem
zusammenhang wie in deutschland haben
ein funktionierendes system der
lohnfindung und der fortschreibung der
von mindestlöhnen
wir sollten dieses bewährte system nicht
ohne not über bord werfen drittens
lassen sie mich betonen es gibt sehr
wohl eine vielzahl von bereichen in
denen wir dringend ein mehr europäische
lösungen benötigen den bereichen bereits
ideen und vorschläge vor
an anderen wird weiter gearbeitet werden
müssten ich nenne zum beispiel im
bereich außen und sicherheit
digitalisierung gesundheitspolitik sowie
migration und asyl
hervorheben möchte ich mich bei in
unerledigten hausaufgaben insbesondere
die reformdebatte zur europäischen
migrations und asylpolitik aktuellen
sinkt zwar die zahl neu gestellten
asylanträge in der eu stark wir müssen
aber genau jetzt diese phase nutzen um
endlich zu einer gemeinsamen tragfähigen
lösung in der europäischen
migrationspolitik zu kommen abschließend
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen möchte
ich sagen inso herausforderungen zeiten
wie diesen braucht es ganz besonders ein
starkes und ein geschlossenes europa
lassen sie uns gemeinsam weiterhin daran
arbeiten vielen herzen
bild florian hahn war das der
europapolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion hierzu vereinbarten
debatte arbeitsprogramm 20 21 der
europäischen kommission
da redet jetzt alexander graf lambsdorff
er war ja selber 13 jahre lang im
eu-parlament von 2014 bis 2017 einer der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden des
europa präsident meine damen und herren
die debatte über das arbeitsprogramm der
europäischen kommission ist immer eine
gute gelegenheit auf europa als ganzes
zu schauen und wenn wir ihnen das
programm selber hineinschauen dann sehen
wir da was die kommission in diesem jahr
tun will sie will europa digitaler und
schneller machen soziale und grüner
demokratische und stärker sie wir
gleichzeitig corona besiegen und sie
will eine konferenz zur zukunft der
europäischen union aufs gleis setzen
das ist das was die europäische
kommission erreichen will
wenn wir uns über fragen womit sie das
erreichen soll womit sie das erreichen
muss dann sind wir natürlich bei dem
thema das außenminister maße gerade
angesprochen hat wir sind beim thema
dessen was die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft an grundlagen gelegt
hat wie deutschlands rolle in europa
aussieht der deutsche bundestag ist der
ort um genau diese fragen zu stellen und
dann ist hier eben von florian hahn
erwähnt worden
der mehrjährige finanzrahmen der
haushalt von dem man sagen muss er es
erneut zu spät
er enthält zu viel festschreibung des
status quo und erhält enthält zu wenig
zukunft er ist gleichzeitig zu national
und zu kleinteilig und man sieht es
besser als am gesamthaushalt am
sonderprogramm next generation eu dass
wir heute morgen im zusammenhang mit der
eigenmittel debatte debattiert haben
wenn sie sich mal anschauen was die
europäische kommission vorgeschlagen hat
an gemeinsamen europäischen programmen
im verhältnis zu dem was die
mitgliedstaaten im einzelnen tun sollen
dann sehen sie das sofort die kommission
begann damit zu sagen wir machen 610
milliarden der 750 für die
mitgliedsstaaten
aber wir investieren in den binnenmarkt
den innovationen digitale sind forschung
70 milliarden was haben die
mitgliedsstaaten gemacht
sie haben den ganzen forschungs und
digital teil von 70 auf 11 milliarden
zusammengestutzt und das geld sich
selber genommen für eigene ausgaben
meine damen und herren so kann europa
nicht funktionieren wenn es national und
kleinteilig betrieben wird und das ist
unter deutscher ratspräsidentschaft
passiert übrigens gilt es auch für die
natürliche umwelt und ihre natürliche
ressourcen und die umwelt von 45 auf 17
und noch besser ist es bei der
nachbarschaftspolitik und der sicherheit
von 25 milliarden komplett auf null
das ganze geld soll zurück fließt in die
nationalstaaten meine damen und herren
das ist nicht die art und weise wie man
gemeinsam in europa politik macht
außerdem soll das geld hier schnell
fließen next generation eu ist das
reaktions programm das reaktions
programm auf die korona krise das geld
kann aber nicht fließen bei derart viel
zu spät dran ist die mitgliedstaaten
haben wir wieder getrödelt wir hier in
diesem wohnhaus werden ist in eigene
monat den beschluss fassen
auf dessen grundlage das geld überhaupt
ausgegeben werden kann
das ist keine schnelle reaktion das ist
trödelei seitens der mitgliedstaaten und
meine damen und herren eine sache
begrüßen wir als freie demokraten
ausdrücklich das geld soll konditioniert
ausgegeben werden das heißt es müssen
klare reformprogramme vorgelegt werden
damit das geld fließen kann
diese reformprogramme werden jetzt schon
eingereicht interessant an der ganzen
geschichte ist dass die kommission dem
deutschen reformprogramm erstmal eine
absage erteilt hat weil es nicht
ambitioniert genug ist und nicht
geeignet ist deutschland aus der korona
krise herauszuführen deutschland zu
schreibt das bert rürup wird vom
reformmotor zu bremse für europa soviel
zur deutschen rolle unter dieser
bundesregierung meine damen und herren
die kommission will
das europa demokratischer wird und hat
deswegen vorgeschlagen an den haushalt
ein rechtsstaats mechanismus zu koppeln
auch das ist etwas das aus liberaler
sicht 1a ist sehr gut was ist aber unter
deutscher ratspräsidentschaft passiert
der rechtsstaat mechanismus wurde erst
ausgehöhlt er heißt jetzt übrigens
formell konditionalität mechanismus auf
so eine idee muss man auch erst mal
kommen
wir wollen wir den ungarn und polen
rechtsstaatlichkeit durchsetzen wenn ein
solcher mechanismus erst ausgehöhlt wird
anschließend lädt irrt wird von den
beiden betroffenen ländern und die
deutsche ratspräsidentschaft steht
blamiert da und kommt praktisch mit
einem beschluss zurück der nicht mehr
ist als das was ein rechnungshof macht
meine damen und herren wenn wir
freiheitliche werte in der europäischen
union schützen wollen dann brauchen
einen starken rechtsstaats mechanismus
hier muss dringend nachgearbeitet werden
thema konferenz zur zukunft europas
auch hierfür hat gerade gesagt das sind
große brocken weggeräumt von dem brocken
der weg geräumt worden ist ist dass dem
rat der vorgesehene vom parlament
vorsitzende dieser konferenz zu
europafreundlich war die verhofstadt der
liberale belgier langjähriger
premierminister belgiens man wollte
ihnen raten nicht haben also hat man
diese konferenz so lange aufgehalten
bis man jetzt im rat ein papier
beschlossen hat in dem steht in dieser
konferenz darf über alles geredet werden
nur nicht über die zukunft europas
einzelne policies dürfen dort besprochen
werden vorschläge für gesetzgebung meine
damen und herren das ist auch ein
ergebnis der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft und das ist kein
zufriedenstellendes ergebnis für die 200
europa zeit ist herr präsident
zum schluss ich wünsche mir dass wir von
deutschland aus eine bessere rolle in
europa spielen ich wünsche der
europäischen kommission viel glück bei
der umsetzung ihres arbeitsprogramms ich
fürchte nur leider dass die grundlagen
nicht gut genug sind die in der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft gelegt
worden sind
herzlichen dank so der nächste redner
hat drei minuten zeit ich bitte alle
diejenigen die noch nicht gewählt haben
diese drei minuten zu nutzen war nach
dem nächsten redner werde ich dann die
wahl schließen also wenn er selber
gewählt hätte wäre es vorteilhaft nein
lieberlieber hat dem in keinem fall man
kann sich auch man kann sie auch draußen
gut hören ja weil sie ja laut genug
sprechen
also bitte in drei minuten nicht ober
und bitte jetzt geht's los
diether dehm ist der nicht trainer von
der linken neustart in diesem
arbeitspapieren die rede wenn schon das
pandemie management der eu ein einziges
desaster war wie soll hier ein neustart
gelingen wo war denn die eu-kommission
und die bundesregierung entgegen ihrem
eigenlob als italien als serbien um
solidarität im vergangenen märz geradezu
gefleht haben das war das gegenteil von
europäischer solidarität im papier steht
nichts vom impfen als opfer vier monaten
nicht absehbar war dass man gelegentlich
pandemien auch mit impfen bekämpfen kann
das nötige hat mein kollege kessler im
tagesordnungspunkt davor gesagt die
bundesregierung hat damals keinerlei
druck auf die eu gemacht die verträge
damals sind mit fahrlässiger
leichtgläubigkeit gestrickt worden darum
die engpässe da wurden sich millionen
der steuerzahler in aktiengesellschaften
gegeben deren gewinne an der börse
erwartet werden solche patente gehören
von anfang an auf gekauft und über
öffentlich-rechtliche firmen den
menschen zur verfügung gestellt und
lasse mich
ein wort zum russischen impfstoff
sputnik frau sagen ich will mich auf das
ihn und er gar nicht einlassen wann
genau die russen bei der ehemaligen
impfstoff beantragt haben herr spahn
hätte sich aktiv darum bemühen müssen
und die informationen hätten transparent
der öffentlichkeit zur verfügung
gestellt werden müssen statt 180 tägigen
sendepause
seit dem august erst august letzten
jahres was budnik fünf anbetrifft was
auch teile der mädchen erfasst hat und
im übrigen das trifft auch für die vier
kubanischen impfstoffe zu da kann man
sich auch noch mal darum bemühen in
welchem zustand sind die welche vorteile
haben sie da wird nichts dazu gesagt
seit dem ersten august liegen
hervorragende resultate vor wird sputnik
in über 30 ländern inklusive eu staaten
inklusive eu-staaten verimpft oder ist
das sputnik am ende deswegen nicht da
weil wir an die an die russland
sanktionen uns gebunden fühlen wegen
navalny der migranten kakerlaken genannt
hat wo bleibt denn der einsatz der eu
wird schuldigen assange der gegen krieg
und aufrüstung kämpft und seine ganz
paris hergestellt hat seit jahren macht
die eu-kommission druck damit die
nationalstaaten am öffentlichen dienst
sparen der stehen vor den trümmern von
gesundheitsämtern die nicht mehr
einzelne theater kita für peter prüfen
kann und deswegen der locker und mit dem
brecheisen wer nicht alles statistisch
und praktische war einen kamm scheren
will braucht personal um mit augenmaß zu
differenzieren damit in braunschweig
nicht wie am sonntag vor einer woche
1500 kulturschaffende mit dem schildern
ihrer untergehenden firmen und
persönlichkeiten dafür kämpfen müssen
dass sowie bei alarmstufe rot sowie im
theater politiker fallen
die alles hygienisch richtig gemein dass
die kultur in europa und in deutschland
überhaupt überleben kann und das ist
eine forderung der linken letzter punkt
wer zahlt der zahl ich konnte mich nicht
erpressen
wer zahlt gelassen den den abstimmungen
jahr noch ein paar sekunden wer zahlt
beim arbeitsprogramm und wer zahlt für
die krise
ich sage ihnen eines und das sagen wir
als linke die digital steuer ist ein
tropfen auf die heiße herdplatte
da ist die eu die eu gar nicht zuständig
und selbst da bremst die bundesregierung
wir sagen wer nicht endlich superreiche
krisengewinnler und steuervermeidung
jeff bezos und latten quandt sozial
gerecht zur kasse zwingt den gelingt
keine frauen kein neustart und der wird
auch nicht schaffen dass die eu neue
sympathien bekommt ich danke für die
aufwartung
nachdem so viele gefesselt waren von der
räte und nicht wählen konnten
machen wir die nächste rednerin noch und
wir schließen danach dann die ja unter
dem meine damen und herren hat sich hier
vor einigen für die kulturschaffenden
eingesetzt er ist ja liedermacher sie
kennen bestimmt das lied tausend mal
berührt tausendmal ist nichts passiert
von klaus lage gesungen aber von dieter
james feder stammen franziska brantner
jetzt für die bündnisgrünen als nicht
wieder in den bundestag
wir haben heute und morgen den
europäischen gipfel es geht um die
gesundheit von uns allen um corona und
um unsere sicherheit
aber leider gibt es wieder einmal vorab
dazu keine regierungserklärung der
kanzlerin
die gab es ja auch nicht vor der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
es gibt sie nicht mehr vor den
europäischen regierungsgipfel ich kann
nur sagen das sind eklatante missachtung
des palais
und damit muss jetzt endlich schluss
sein dafür sprechen wir heute über das
arbeitsprogramm der europäischen
kommission und das ist ambitioniert aber
ob die umsetzung ambitioniert sein wird
das hängt von den mitgliedstaaten ab ob
sie als bundesregierung endlich von der
bremse kommen und ein gutes beispiel
dafür ist der klimaschutz der green
dienen
sie haben den klimaschutz in ihrer
ratspräsidentschaft total vernachlässigt
die einigung zu den klimazielen
innerhalb der mitgliedsstaaten kam erst
im dezember
und deswegen laufen jetzt immer noch die
verhandlung zum klimaschutzgesetz sie
sind erst im märz beim gipfel wieder auf
der tagesordnung damit haben wir so viel
wertvolle zeit verloren die wir
eigentlich gar nicht haben und die
europäische kommission hat die
bundesregierung jetzt vor den
europäischen gerichtshof gebracht weil
sie seit jahren die
vertragsverletzungsverfahren beim
naturschutz recht einfach ignorieren
dass es unglaublich dass sie das
europäische naturschutzrecht bei uns
nicht umsetzen und das ist ein
armutszeugnis dass wir jetzt vor dem
europäischen gerichtshof deswegen sind
und auch der totalausfall bei der
agrarpolitik trägt die handschrift von
julia klöckner
es gehen weiterhin die milliarden in die
agro industrie statt endlich die
agrarwende voranzubringen
und dabei ist es wirklich zeit jetzt mit
diesen hilfsmilliarden den wien die ihn
auch wirklich umzusetzen und da muss die
agrarpolitik ihren beitrag dazu leisten
gehen sie
auf der von der bremse sie verschleppen
bei allen themen den europäischen green
deal weil sie auch angst davor haben
dass sie dann zuhause ihn ja auch
umsetzen müssten und frau merkel sie
muss sich heute beim europäischen gipfel
zu recht viel kritik von ihren
kolleginnen anhören minister seehofer
hat nämlich vor drei wochen wieder mal
unabgestimmte grenzkontrollen erlassen
und damit die grenzregion ins chaos
gestürzt sie nachbarn düpiert und die
fehler der ersten welle wiederholt es
ist wirklich ärgerlich dass wir wieder
in einer situation sind das zum beispiel
unverheiratete paare sich wieder nicht
sehen könnt und verheiratete paare auch
nur gleichzeitig einreisen dürfen
es dürfen momentan aus portugal nicht
mal die ehefrau einreisen wenn der
ehemann in deutschland ist geht nicht
die müssen gleichzeitig einreißen das
ist doch ein absoluter wahnsinn und es
ist einfach nur ärgerlich dass wir
diesen großen mist wieder haben den wir
schon in einem halben jahr hatten und es
ist wirklich nicht erträglich dass sie
immer noch keine straße eingesetzt haben
für die grenzregion dass sie während der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft diese
probleme nicht rechtzeitig angegangen
sind
und jetzt wieder unsere europäischen
partner sich hier berechtigterweise über
uns ärgern und das gleiche gilt mit
blick auf die frage der
impfstoffproduktion wir wissen dass es
besser gewesen wäre wenn die europäische
union nicht nur gemeinsam bestellt
sondern auch gemeinsam bezahlt hätte wir
wissen mittlerweile dass es richtig
gewesen wäre nicht nur in die innovation
zu investieren sondern auch in die
produktion
diesen fehler liegen aber nicht nur an
der europäischen kommission sondern auch
an den mitgliedstaaten die in dem
lenkungskreis ständig und regelmäßig
involviert sind und deswegen habe ich
mich gewundert oder ja wirklich
erschreckt darüber dass die spd die
täglich darüber mit informiert es
mitgemacht hat im herbst dann auf einmal
im frühjahr jetzt die europäische
kommission dafür an greift das ist
wirklich einfach nur wahlkampf und
schadet der europäischen union
und jetzt haben wir eine europäische
impfstoff taskforce bariton sie haben
seit letzter woche auch einen nationalen
stoff beauftragen das ist alles einfach
viel zu spät
und jetzt würden wahrscheinlich viele
sagen das haben wir den schnelltests
beauftragten wenn wir die debatte von
vorhin verfolgt haben und als nächstes
werden wir den beauftragten für corona
medikamente brauchen
es ist absehbar dass wir immer bei den
notwendigen medizinischen produkten
engpässe haben das war schon so bei den
masken und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt
endlich auf europäischer ebene ein
vergleichbares instrument wie es die
amerikaner auch machen um zu
koordinieren zu regulieren und zu
investieren
bei all dem medizinischen produkten die
wir brauchen entlang der lieferketten
und ich erhoffe mir wirklich dass die
bundesregierung der master sie sich
jetzt massiv dafür einsetzen dass der
vorschlag der europäischen kommission
wer also ein ähnliches institutionelles
vereine eine agentur aufzubauen
die diese aufgaben übernehmen können es
ist spät in der pandemie aber vielleicht
noch nicht zu spät fangen sie jetzt an
hier endlich richtig druck rein zu
bekommen damit wir hier schneller bei
den nächsten wahlen ganz hoffentlich vor
der welle sind und nicht wieder
hinterher hätten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
cdu die eu kommission hat auch mit blick
auf rechtsstaatlichkeit sich einiges
vorgenommen aber da liegt eine große
aufgabe bei ihnen schließen sie sich
jetzt endlich den 14 länder relegation
ihrer eigenen schwester parteien an
machen sie endlich den schritt und
sprechen sie sich dafür aus die partei
von viktor orban vieles aus der
europäischen konservativen volkspartei
rauszuschmeißen
das wäre einer der erfolgreichsten hebe
die wir haben im kampf für
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie in
europa hier muss cdu und cdu jetzt
endlich mal farbe bekennen für
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie die
kollegen können ich komme zurück zu den
bauern die zeit für die wahl ist gleich
vorbei
da fragen ist noch ein mitglied des
hauses anwesende seine stimme nicht
abgegeben hat vorsitzende hans peter
friedrich schließt jetzt die wahl zu den
vorschlägen der fdp zu den besetzungen
der gremien vertrauensgremium gemäß der
bundeshaushaltsordnung gremium gemäß des
bunten schiff bundesschulden gesetzes
und das sondergremium gemäß den
stabilisierungsmechanismus gesetzt haben
die afd
hier drei wahlvorschläge machte bis
jetzt konnten die abgeordneten abstimmen
jetzt ist die abstimmung geschlossenes
ergebnis liefern wie hindern wenn es vor
dem bremer jetzt für den titel eine
vitale union in einer fragilen welt ich
habe mich sehr gefreut dass die
kommissarin dalia eine mehrjährige
gleichstellungs strategie aufgelegt hat
und ich habe mich auch darüber gefreut
dass keine dieser gleichstellung
strategie sich in diesem arbeitsprogramm
wiederfinden das ist gut so und man hat
das gefühl
es geht immer vorwärts und es ist auch
benötigt dass es vorwärts geht und im
21er programm steht auch ganz konkret
drin was die europäische kommission beim
kampf gegen geschlechtsspezifische
gewalt unternehmen will und da denkst du
es geht vorwärts und in kleinen
schritten in trippelschritten aber immer
in eine richtung aber die wahrheit ist
dass wir recht maßgebliche teile dieser
europäischen union haben da geht's
einfach mastiff rückwärts massiv
rückwärts wir schauen uns also konkret
nach polen
wir wissen es wir haben in polen
inzwischen ein verbot des verschreiben
es von verhütungsmitteln an unter 18
jährige
es ist der sexualaufklärung in schulen
betreibt wird dafür bestraft abtreibung
ist aufgrund fragwürdiger
gerichtsentscheidungen in polen faktisch
legal nicht mehr möglich und wer jetzt
glaubt dass abtreibung legal nicht
möglich ist dass er den abgeschafft ist
irgend natürlich wir haben ja auch
unsere erfahrungen mit dem thema wenn
sie legal möglich ist dann geht es eben
in untergrund und dann wird es
gefährlich für die frauen bei uns waren
sie früher am küchentisch gelegen
auf dem küchentisch und so wird im
zweifel in polen auch sein und das ist
es was wir nicht wollen wir wollen auch
dass frauen zugang haben zu
verhütungsmitteln und zur
familienplanung die gesetzt
moment holt und die rechte der
rechtsprechung sind von tage angriff auf
die selbstbestimmungsrechte frauen und
polen kann die bedenken zum jüngsten
abtreibungs urteil zur unabhängigkeit
und legitimität des gerichts nicht
ausräumen
beim bunten ballon partie gestern im
frauenausschuss der europäischen union
des europaparlaments lebhaft berichtet
hat wie es zugeht im in polen die
protestierende frauen ihre arbeitsplätze
verlieren und trotz der zweifelhaften
gerichtsentscheidungen immer wieder
aufstehen
lampert fordert uns eindrücklich auf für
sie und mitgliedern zu kämpfen denn es
geht um die grundrechte der europäischen
union und ich rufe frau lampert von
diesem platz aus zu die demokratischen
teile dieses parlaments stehen an der
seite der engagierten frauen und männer
empfohlen die nichts weiter rollen als
die reformkräfte als europäische
grundrechte und der wir haben jetzt aber
was gehört
in actionreichen der angst der frauen
und männer in polen um die rechte da ist
ein kampf um die rechte der nächsten
generation in polen auch in deutschland
und in europa und ich finde die
kommission darf dass der polnischen
regierung einfach nicht durchgehen
lassen
[Applaus]
für die fraktion der afg hat das wort
professor doktor harald weiss
[Applaus]
herr präsident geehrte kollegen und sehr
geehrte publikum arbeitsprogramm sind
absichtserklärungen der man weiß ja nie
was kommt
die eu kommission hat das gerade in der
frage der impfstoff beschaffung zu
spüren bekommen so dass ihre vollmundige
ankündigung sich an die spitze der
weltweiten krisenreaktion zur
beschaffung eines sicheren impfstoffes
für alle zu stellen als makulatur
betrachtet werden kann
wir können nur hoffen dass sich die
anderen vorhaben ebenso schnell in luft
auflösen
ihre umsetzung wäre fatal für
deutschlands zukunft die hier auf dem
altar des multilateralismus geopfert
wird
zu den punkten des programms der
europäischen grünen new deal klingt wie
ein märchen mal abgesehen vom denglisch
was in den ohren schmerzt alles wird gut
und öko das ist unsinn und das wissen
sie auch jedes elektroauto ist eine
fahrbare sondermülldeponie die uns
obendrein davon abhält echte innovative
mobilität zu entwickeln und die neue
digitale industrie strategie für europa
basiert schon in den grundsätzen auf
eine lüge nämlich dass dort von freie
meinungsäußerung und freien datenfluss
die rede ist
wir müssen uns dazu nur an den
verhaltenskodex zur bekämpfung illegaler
hassreden im internet erinnern
mit anderen worten den digitalen
hengsten hammer oder auch hexenhammer
des digitalen zeitalters wie künftige
historiker sicher nicht konstatieren
werden auch die europäische sollen
soziale rechte wird genau kein kompass
für die erholung europas sein
die vertiefung der wirtschafts und
währungsunion hat bislang nämlich nur
zwei dinge erreicht sie hat die deutsche
schuldknechtschaft verstetigt und die
südländer an das gift der
dauersubvention gewöhnt er lächerlich
wird es wenn von der geopolitischen
kommission die rede ist die in einer
zunehmend polarisierten welt 1 regel und
werte basieren
internationale ordnung verteidigen
möchte hier klaffen anspruch und
wirklichkeit so weit auseinander dass
die kommission möglicherweise nur wenig
schaden anrichten können wird anders
sieht es mit der arbeit am neuen
migrations und asylpolitik und päckchen
aus groß paket möchte man sagen dass
bislang gerade für deutschland so
schadens trächtig wie nur möglich war
und ist
wenn diese linie weiter verfolgt wird
dann haben wir bislang nur die spitze
des einwanderungs eisbergs gesehen und
sie rufen ja letzten endes nach der
totalen migration die wollen wir nicht
nein nein und nochmals nein wie eine
drohung ließ sich schließlich was unser
neuer schwung für die demokratie in
europa sein soll
jede eu kritik wird nämlich als
antidemokratisch diffamiert und die
gängelung der mitgliedstaaten genüsslich
angekündigt also ein weiterer abschwung
der demokratie in eu ropa steht bevor
wer so ein arbeitsprogramm beklatscht
und unterstützt versündigt sich an
unserer nation sondern auch an seinen
nachkommen an unserer unterstützung und
auf unsere unterstützung können sie
nicht rechnen
danke liebe kolleginnen kollegen falls
noch schriftführer unter ihnen sind es
werden noch schriftführer gebrauch zum
auszählen
vielleicht können auch die beiden
deutschen geschäftsführer mal bitten
dass noch der eine oder andere
schriftführer sich im aus zellerau
einfindet damit wird die wahlen zügig
aus zählen können und die in extremeren
ist jetzt in dieser debatte die kollegin
dr katja reichert zugleich
stellvertreter fraktionsvorsitzender der
unionsfraktion sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wie europäer sind mittendrin in der
bewältigung der krise
und es ist sensationell dass wir ein
jahr nach ausbruch der pandemie bis dato
schon 27 millionen dosen impfstoff
geimpft haben einiges hätte natürlich
noch besser laufen können ja und genau
deshalb sind wir auch alle gefragt die
europäische union weiter zu stärken
denn eins ist auch klar ein virus kennt
keine nationalen grenzen
und genau dafür ist die europäische
union da sie soll die großen probleme
lösen und genau an diesem anspruch
orientiert sich auf das arbeitsprogramm
der kommission für uns als cdu csu
fraktion ist dabei besonders wichtig
erstens gesunde finanzen und jobs jobs
jobs liebe kolleginnen kollegen
wirtschaftlich stehen wir in der welt an
einem wendepunkt wie nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg ich erklärte ihnen gern
nochmal kleinwächter und daher ist es
genau richtig dass die europäische union
mit dem aufbau vor das größte konjunktur
und reformprogramm ihrer geschichte
aufgelegt hat 750 milliarden für
investitionen und schon jetzt zeigt sich
der erfolg die spread zwischen
italienischen und deutschen
staatsanleihen sowas erwähnen sie hier
nämlich nicht sind so gering wie seit
jahren nicht mehr
und wenn sie sich die wechselkurse
anschauen der euro hat gegenüber dem
us-dollar und dem fund im letzten jahr
stark zugelegt der euro ist mittlerweile
das weltweit am häufigsten genutzte
zahlungsmittel und ohne diesen vor
hätten natürlich spekulanten freie hand
gehabt auf den untergang des euros zu
wetten und am ende hätte es in europa
nur verlierer gegeben europa wäre
auseinander gedriftet
aber eines ist dabei auch ganz klar wir
europäer haben gemeinsam mit diesem
fonds einen scheck auf die zukunft
ausgestellt und dieser scheck ist weder
ein freifahrtschein noch eine
dauerlösung alle mitgliedstaaten müssen
jetzt reform liefern haushaltslöcher
dürfen damit natürlich nicht gestopft
werden
und es ist meine feste überzeugung dass
wir
solidarität brauchen die europäische
union darf nach außen eben keine
angriffsfläche bieten
aber dann braucht es genauso auch die
finanzielle solidität nach innen und
genau deshalb ist es richtig dass wir
nach der krise so schnell wie möglich
wieder zurück kommen zum stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie mich zu meinem
zweiten punkt kommt zum thema
klimaschutz
ich begrüße es dass sich alle
mitgliedstaaten nicht zuletzt dank des
einsatzes unserer kanzlerin auf zwei
wichtige punkte geeinigt haben erstens
auf klimaneutralität bis 2050 und
zweitens auf die verringerung der
treibhausgasemissionen bis 20.30 um 55
prozent
die kommission arbeitet an zwölf
vorschlägen zur umsetzung dieser ziele
von der reform der erneuerbaren energien
richtlinie über die co2 grenzsteuersatz
zur anpassung des co2 zertifikate
handels und gerade letzterer ist ein
erfolgsmodell made in europe
seit beginn des europaweiten
emissionshandel in der eu sind die ets
emission um 35 prozent zurückgegangen
und liebe frau prantner aller
wertschätzung wie verschleppen hier gar
nichts deshalb fordern wir auch die
ausweitung des ets auf eu ebene bei
gebäude und verkehr genauso wie wir das
jetzt hier bei uns in deutschland
gemacht haben und das zeigt doch liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen für eine
ambitionierte klimapolitik brauchen wir
keine spuren ideologen wir brauchen auch
nicht die afd
die noch nie eine echte antwort auf
große herausforderung gegeben hat
kindisch über kreta sport und ansonsten
den klimawandel leugnet wir brauchen
ernsthaftigkeit und vernunft und diese
große transformation zu meistern
und genau deshalb wollen wir unsere
wirtschaft nachhaltig
modernisieren sie soll wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben und wir wollen globale standards
setzen und das liebe kolleginnen
kollegen gelingt am besten unter
christdemokratischer führung in brüssel
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie alle
wissen dass wir bei digitalen
endprodukten ins hintertreffen geraten
sind das muss man feststellen
schauen sie jetzt aber nicht traurig auf
ihr handy die europäische union hat viel
vor
sie ordnet den marktplatz für digitales
komplett neu digital service ecktisch
markets act arra governance richtlinie
und das alles wird am ende zu einem
besseren und vor allem väter sind
marktumfeld für digitalwirtschaft in
europa führen damit erledigt die
kommission ihrem job als hüterin des
binnenmarktes und hat dabei unsere volle
unterstützung
aber das kann natürlich nur der erste
schritt sein allein mit regulierung
holen wir nicht mehr auf wir brauchen
ein europäisches digitales ökosystem in
dem wissenschaft forschung wirtschaft
und politik für neue produkte eng
miteinander verknüpft werden wir
brauchen mehr menschen die alexander
jung dietmar hopp und frank thelen die
als europäer für diskussionen auf dem
digitalen markt sorgen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen egal ob
es ums impfen geht um die wirtschaft um
den klimawandel oder um digitales gerade
wir deutsche werden nur als europäer
wieder aus dieser krisen kommen
unterstützen wir also das
arbeitsprogramm der europäischen
kommission vielen dank weil digitalen
ist es so dass das arbeitsprogramm
unter anderem sagt ein fahrplan soll
ziele zur digitalisierung bis 2030 auf
stellen darunter vorgaben zur
netzanbindung und zur digitalisierung
der öffentlichen verwaltung der
klimawandel spielt natürlich auch eine
rolle bei diesem arbeitsprogramm und
wirft schon einen hinweis sozusagen auf
den nächsten redner das ist nämlich der
klimapolitische sprecher der liberalen
lukas kohler
sehr geehrter präsident meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen ich finde die
frau habe gerade ganz ganz ganz klugen
satz gesagt und zwar den satz dass die
eu dazu da ist die großen probleme zu
lösen und ich glaube dass das genau der
richtige ansatz ist die große frage ist
aber sind wir da auf dem richtigen weg
wir sehen das riesige brocken vor uns
liegen wir sehen das gerade in der
diskussion um den green deal um die 55
prozent dass da die knackpunkte in den
details legen und auch übrigens in den
details der internen verhandlungen und
wir müssen heute wir können heute dafür
sorgen dass die chancen die die
klimapolitik bietet das ist viel geld
aber vor allen dingen die viele
innovationen der einzelnen der tüftler
der denker der ingenieure dass das
umgesetzt wird und das ist doch eine
tolle nachricht ist doch super dass wir
es jetzt schaffen können die zukunft zu
gestalten und das ist das kommende jahr
der ins entscheidende zeitraum sein wird
indem wir das tun
die eu möchte so recht den europäischen
emissionshandel ausweiten das ist
tatsächlich einer der wenigen wege wie
wir wirklich klimaschutz zielgerichtet
voranbringen können es ist aber noch ein
anderer guter grund dafür warum wir das
tun sollten der emissionshandel und die
ausweitung würde verhindern würde es
erleichtern dass wir die diskussion um
die anderen bereiche da wo es nicht
funktioniert die bereiche verkehr die
bereiche wärme nicht mehr weiter im
adwords sharing behandeln müssen sondern
dass wir da dafür sorgen können dass wir
eine einheitliches ziel haben dass wir
klimapolitik und das bestätigen sogar
die kritiker des emissionshandels dass
wir klimapolitik zielgerichtet auf das
1,5 grad ziel umsetzen können und das
muss doch das sein was wir tun
wir müssen klug effiziente klimapolitik
machen die zu möglichst wenig kosten das
maximum herausholt und die ziele die wir
wissenschaftlich gesetzt bekommen auch
umsetzen und das ist das was wir tun
können das ist das was die eu tun kann
aber wir müssen noch deutlich weiter
darüber hinaus gehen die kommission
diskutiert wird für 55
aber für 55 muss auch gleichzeitig
heißen dass wir heute die diskussion
über negativ emissionen dass wir heute
die diskussion um ccs anfangen deswegen
schlagen wir freie demokraten vor dass
wir zusätzlich zu 55 prozent ziel ein
weiteres 5 prozent ziel negative
emissionen machen
meine damen und herren wenn sie das
einbringen dann kriegen sie aus der
wissenschaft viel lob weil die sagen ja
endlich sagt es mal jemand endlich wird
das mal eingefordert das was wir heute
brauchen auch heute schon zu diskutieren
aber als kritik kommt dann und das war
des öfteren so kommt dann ja das ist
eine technologie die brauchen wir die
katzen mission brauchen wir ja aber wir
brauchen wir erst in 30 jahren
wer diese argumentation anfängt sagt
dass wir in 30 jahren vor dem problem
stehen werden dass wir dann nicht
darüber diskutiert haben sagt dass wir
in 30 jahren etwas nicht geschafft haben
was wir hätten längst umsetzen können
und umsetzen sollen deswegen es ist
schade dass wir uns aus angst vor der
diskussion diesen punkten nicht stellen
dass wir uns aus angst der diskussion
nicht für technologie für chancen für
möglichkeiten in der wirtschaft in der
entwicklung in der innovation einsetzen
das wäre etwas das wir auch auf
europäischer ebene tun können ich hoffe
darauf ich glaube daran dass wir auf
europäischer ebene gemeinsam viel
erreichen können dazu müssen wir aber
auch die kritischen punkte ansprechen
und ich vertraue darauf dass wir das im
nächsten jahr gemeinsam tun werden
vielen dank
europa will ja der erste klimaneutrale
kontinent werden die eu soll bis 2050
klimaneutral sein nächster redner hier
in der aussprache zum arbeitsprogramm
der europäischen kommission 2021 wird
andrej hunko sein der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
herr außenminister maß sie sprachen eben
davon dass man mit blick auf das wie ich
es formulieren würde impfstoff
beschaffungs fiasko der eu fehler
eingestehen müssen sehr gut so weit aber
es wäre leichter das zu akzeptieren wenn
konsequenzen daraus gezogen würden und
wenn in dem arbeitsprogramm der eu
kommission über das wir heute reden
nicht eine solche überheblichkeit drin
wäre wo zum beispiel steht europa wird
an der spitze der weltweiten impfstoff
beschaffung stehen
dieser widerspruch der ist unerträglich
und das muss man hier auch klar sagen
dass kleine land in europa das kleine
land mit großer republikanischer
tradition san marino hat in den letzten
wochen verzweifelt versucht über die eu
oder über italien impfstoffe zu bekommen
wenigstens einen einzigen impfstoff sie
haben nichts bekommen und haben
vorgestern angefangen mit dem russischen
impfstoff sputnik 5 zu impfen
ähnlich sieht die lage auf dem
westbalkan aus in serbien eines der
spitzenreiter jetzt kein eu
mitgliedsstaat sind mittlerweile über 15
prozent der menschen geimpft und die
menschen können sich aussuchen ob sie
einen westlichen impfstoff nehmen ob sie
den russischen impfstoff nehmen oder
einen stoff von sinopharm aus china und
ich finde
ich finde es beschämend wenn ein land
das beitrittskandidat der eu ist so viel
weiter ist in dieser frage als die
meisten eu mitgliedstaaten oder sogar
alle diese überheblichkeit des
durchzieht dieses arbeitsprogramms in
puncto deutschlands rolle in der welt
gestern ist in venezuela
die deutsch die eu botschafterin isabel
brillante ausgewiesen worden weil die eu
anfang dieser woche nichts besseres zu
tun hatte als neue sanktionen gegen
menschen in venezuela auszusprechen und
sowohl von der regierung und sogar von
der opposition die an den
parlamentswahlen im dezember
teilgenommen haben
das ist aus unserer sicht völlig falsch
und wenige tage nachdem in venezuela die
uno sonderberichterstatter in alena du
haben dort einen bericht über die folgen
sondern berichterstatterin zudem vor
negativen auswirkungen einseitiger
zwangsmaßnahmen die er eindringlich
appelliert habt die sanktionen gegen
venezuela endlich zu beenden
ich glaube zusammenfassend zu sagen wenn
wir auf deutsche auf die rolle der eu in
der welt und das ist ja ein großes thema
in diesem arbeitsprogramm schauen dann
wäre es sehr gut wenn die europäische
union sehr viel mehr auf kooperation auf
augenhöhe mit anderen regionen der welt
setzt als auf überheblichkeit als auf
sanktionen als auch die vorstellung dass
man überall richtig sein kann und ich
glaube dass dann die guten ziele die
hier auch in dem arbeitsprogramm
formuliert sind wie etwa den klimawandel
im kampf gegen den klimawandel für die
biodiversität und viele viele andere
dinge sehr viel besser umsetzbar sind
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
andrej hunko war das für die
linksfraktionen nächster redner hier in
der aussprache
das ist der vorsitzende des ausschusses
für die angelegenheiten der europäischen
union das ist der abgeordnete
gunther krichbaum er spricht für die cdu
csu fraktion
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen
die europäische kommission hat ein
arbeitsprogramm vorgelegt das sechs
prioritäten setzt das ohne jeden zweifel
sehr ehrgeizig ist weil es auf die
nächsten 12 monate ausgerichtet ist und
eines herstellen soll nämlich
transparenz und damit auch vertrauen der
bürgerinnen bürger der wirtschaft hat
unternehmen das ist der tiefere sinn das
handeln der europäischen kommission
offen zu legen
und wenn jetzt hier verschiedentlich
auch von seiten der linken behauptet
wurde herr dr dem hat gesagt das thema
impfen spielt da gar keine rolle
herr hugo hat danach gesagt ja man wolle
sich an die spitze der welt setzen würde
ich gerne aus dem arbeitsprogramm
zitieren mit erlaubnis des präsidenten
vor diesem hintergrund wird sich die
kommission im kommenden jahr vor allem
auf zweierlei konzentrieren
erstens wird sie sich weiterhin nach
kräften darum bemühen die krise zu
bewältigen und die ersten lehren daraus
zu ziehen
zu diesem zweck wird sie insbesondere
ihre bemühungen im hinblick darauf
fortsetzen
einen sicheren und verfügbaren impfstoff
zu finden und zu finanzieren und dafür
zu sorgen dass diese alle menschen in
europa und weltweit reicht und vor allem
das letztere erscheint mir richtig
weltweit für unter und unterhalten uns
sehr stark über die verfügbarkeit des
impfstoffes in deutschland das ist alles
nachvollziehbar um auch in europa aber
wir dürfen den blick auch davor nicht
vorstellen dass in vielen ländern dieser
welt noch überhaupt nicht damit begonnen
wurde zu impfen
da denke ich vor allem an die vielen
afrikanischen ländern und auch dafür
haben wir als europäische union und vor
allem als bundesrepublik deutschland
eine verantwortung die prioritäten
wurden ja bereits benannt
europäischer rhöner deal ein europa das
für das digitale zeitalter gerüstet ist
eine wirtschaft im dienste der menschen
ein stärkeres europa in der welt fördern
was europa ausmacht neuer schwung für
die demokratien in europa um sie
namentlich zu nennen
aber die oberste priorität gilt
selbstverständlich der überwindung der
korona krise kroner darf aber nicht
davor den blick verstellen dass es auch
an anderen stellen um die sicherung des
europäischen wirtschaftsstandortes geht
der mit corona sehr viel zu tun hat aber
was mit der korona krise nur bedingt zu
tun hat was meine ich dieser trage
erreichen uns meldungen wonach die firma
renault ich kann jetzt gewisse namen
nicht vermeiden
wegen mangelnder elektronikbauteile im
laufenden jahr vermutlich ungefähr
100.000 autos weniger bauen wird das
eigentliche dilemma wird erst
ersichtlich werden in diesem jahr in den
monaten zwischen april und juni
das gilt aber auch für
automobilhersteller wie beispielsweise
verwegen
auch da ist es so dass vor allem die
engpässe bei der halbleiterproduktion
beziehungsweise belieferung für einen
rückgang automobilindustrie der
automobilproduktion sorgen wird vw genau
aus diesem grund kurzarbeit in wolfsburg
anmelden die rede ist von aktuell 8000
mitarbeiter und die davon betroffen sind
diese diskussion wird wirft ein
schlaglicht darauf wie wir in diesem
bereich aufgestellt sind und so wie wir
noch vor zwei jahren nicht daran gedacht
hätten dass vielleicht einmal
medizinische schutzmaske knapp werden
könnten in europa so müssen wir jetzt
und heute darauf reagieren dass in ganz
anderen stellen die wirtschaftliche
prosperität dieser europäischen union
und damit auch der bundesrepublik
deutschland auf eine ernsthafte probe
gestellt wird
deswegen und da begrüße ich ausdrücklich
die bereits getroffenen und gestarteten
europäischen initiativen
und auch die bundesdeutschen deswegen
war auch gestern und wirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier und seine
staatssekretärin frau winkelmeier-becker
bei uns im europaausschuss gilt es vor
allem jetzt richtig die weichen zu
stellen
wir sind auf sehr bedenkliche art und
weise abhängig von amerikanischen
märkten
damit meine ich nicht nur die produktion
sondern auch die distribution nur als
eine zahl genannt was die
halbleiterproduktion angeht zehn
hersteller machen zwei drittel des
gesamten weltmarktes aus und von denen
sind acht beziehungsweise die große
überwiegende zahl us amerikanische
unternehmen nur eines inszenieren ist
hier aus europa wir müssen deswegen
dringend darauf achten dass wir hier die
richtigen akzente für die zukunft setzen
denn nur eines sei auch bemerkt wenn die
distributoren auch in amerikanischer
hand liegen selbst in deutscher selbst
den europäischer in dem moment sind
daten der zulieferung auf einer
amerikanischen cloud das regel wird auch
an claire stelle sichtbar wir brauchen
auch die europäische cloud wir müssen
uns hier wesentlich zukunftsfähiger
aufstellt sonst kommen wir hier in ein
großes dilemma herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und
[Applaus]
für die unionsfraktion hat darauf
hingewiesen dass in vielen ländern ja
noch gar nicht begonnen wurde zu impfen
und das ist schon auch ein bisschen an
hinweise auf die nächste auf dem
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt da wird es
nämlich tatsächlich um die globale
bekämpfung von kubik 19 gehen also das
wird sicher auch noch interessant diese
bleibe aber noch hier in der debatte mit
axel schäfer für die spd im bundestag
führen sollten die pro europäischen
parteien und fraktionen dieses hauses
bitte auch immer europäisch fördern
das heißt wir dürfen an eine kommission
der politikerinnen und politiker von
liberalen sozialdemokraten
christdemokraten grünen sogar ein linker
angehört dürfen wir keine andere
maßstäbe anlegen als wir das aktuell bei
unseren schwierigen debatten in corona
über das verhältnis bundestag und
regierung und auf der anderen seite
bundesrat tun
wir haben alle eine große gemeinsame
verantwortung in diesem land in dieser
außergewöhnlichen herausforderung und
wir haben die in vergleichbaren
konstellationen auch in der eu deshalb
bitte nie nach dem prinzip wenn morgens
früh die sonne lacht hat dieses unser
land vollbracht doch gibt s matsch und
schnee dann war es die eg oder jetzt eu
und bitte nie nach diesem prinzip und
ich einig
und ich sage dass ich sage das ganz ich
sage das ganz bewusst
ich sage das ganz bewusst wir sitzen ja
im parlament abgeordnete die früher im
ep wann wieder kollege lambsdorff die
kollegin weisgerber die kollegin
brandner der kollekte maße oder auch
martin schulz ich übrigens auch und wir
wissen doch dass es bei jeder
europadebatte wenn man die wirklich
ernst nimmt nur darum gehen kann dass
man aus einer nationalen perspektive
immer auch die europäische im sinne der
eigenen partei familien mit einbezieht
denn sonst funktioniert es nicht es geht
kritisch gegen die kommission nur wer
das selbst kritisch gegen eigene
position nimmt sonst funktionieren
europa nicht und deshalb und deshalb bin
ich klar davon überzeugt die
kommissionspräsidentin ist bekanntlich
eine christdemokratin dass die
eu-kommission im letzten jahr und mit
dem was ihr arbeitsprogramm vorlegt
wegweisendes tod und dinge vorangebracht
hat in einer historischen situation die
wir einordnen müssen und nicht
kleinreden dürfen wir uns das an corona
ist ja nur ein punkt wer hätte vor einem
jahr gedacht wie schnell wir gemeinsam
in europa in der lage während impfstoffe
zu entwickeln
wir waren nie in einer situation dass
wir zeitgleich bewältigen mussten einen
halbwegs geordneten austritt eines
landes stichwort braig sind wir machen
selbst die innere situation dass wir
finanzen regeln mussten und was völlig
neues vorangebracht habe
jetzt mit dem mit dem zukunftsfonds ist
finanziell gesehen fast so etwas wie
eine europäische revolution und das
ganze auf dem hintergrund dass wir die
klimakrise bewältigen müssen das ist
möglich gewesen in dieser und mit dieser
kommission und deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir im deutschen bundestag
einerseits versäumnisse im einzelnen
diskutieren und kritisieren aber
andererseits das immer zugewandt machen
was in europa gelungen ist und wissend
oder es auch manchmal sagen dass wir als
eu die standards auf dieser welt setzen
dass wir standards was datenschutz was
gesundheit sicherheit was
handelsbeziehung aber lang die werden
von europa gesetzt die haben wir
demokratisch teilweise in sehr großen
koalition oder konstellationen
hinbekommen das ist ein stück unserer
selbstbewusster und deshalb sollten wir
genau das hier auch vor uns hertragen
und jetzt mache ich eine persönliche
bemerkung nach über 20 jahren
zusammenarbeit mit elmar brok mit mit
gunther krichbaum jetzt auch mit mit
andreasen
ich habe an keinen zweifel an der
europäischen integrität der
christdemokraten
aber es kann nicht sein dass die
christdemokratische partei ungarns den
fraktionsvorsitzenden ihrer eigenen
familien manfred weber csu
mit gestapo und statistischen methoden
vergleicht als unakzeptabel da stelle
ich mich auch in jeder beziehung vor
manfred weber
und ich bitte euch wirklich völlig
unabhängig von bad ems und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu csu
sagt euro
den parteivorsitzenden armin laschet
muss raus geschmissen werden das sind
keine christdemokraten dass die
nationalisten die gehören nicht in eine
hohe europäische partei vergeben sagt
hier axel schäfer für die spd fraktion
ist zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt der
unionsfraktion und investitionen
arbeitsprogrammen der europäischen
kommission hier noch einen redner zu
diesem tagesordnungspunkt christian
natterer für die unionsfraktion sehr
geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ein bürger aus
meinem wahlkreis im dreiländereck in
weil am rhein berichtete der badischen
zeitung im april 2020 wie schwierig es
ist seine arbeit in basel nachzugehen
und gleichzeitig seine lebensgefährtin
im elsass zu besuchen
frankreich schweiz deutschland
normalerweise würde er die grenzen dort
gar nicht wahrnehmen
doch seit dem ausbruch der cholera
pandemie hat sich seine realität
schlagartig verändert denn zu beginn der
krise schien all das wofür wir in europa
lange und hart gekämpft hatten ins
wanken zu geraten
die geschlossenen grenzen betreffen
dabei wie im eben noch selten beispiel
sehr konkret das leben unserer bürger
ein schleier des egoismus und der
verschlossenheit viel über europa bilder
endloser lkw staus waren ein symbol der
plötzlich da gewesenen angst um die
allgemeine versorgungslage in der eu
masken und schutzanzügen steckten
zunächst in den europäischen häfen fest
in erinnerungen an die zeiten vor
schengen waren wieder präsent kurzum die
in europäische freizügigkeit ein
zentraler pfeiler unseres liebgewonnenen
vereinten europas schien bedroht
problemen und krisen dieser art sind
aber nur gemeinsam zu bewältigen
deshalb brauchen wir zukunft
nicht weniger sondern mehr europa ich
begrüße daher ausdrücklich das
arbeitsprogramm der eu-kommission
welches auch über die pandemie hinaus
konkrete und zukunftsorientierte
lösungen anbietet dabei möchte ich vor
allem auf zwei zentrale punkte eingehen
den klimaschutz und die verkehrspolitik
zwei eng miteinander verzahnte themen
eine nachhaltige verkehrspolitik auf
europäischer ebene ist unerlässlich die
von der eu vorgeschlagenen massnahmen
erachte ich als sinnvoll an und fordere
dabei weiter der schritte die
transeuropäischen verkehrsachsen die
sogenannten ten projekte müssen weiter
fortgeschrieben und vor allem schneller
umgesetzt worden
ein prominentes und immer wieder genannt
das beispiel ist der ein korridor mit
der ausbaustrecke karlsruhe basel im
zuge der ten achse rotterdam genua unter
anderem das größte verkehrsprojekt in
meinem südbadischen wahlkreis
dies würde nicht nur eine beschleunigung
der verkehr in europa insgesamt bedeuten
sondern auch zu einer entlastung der vom
verkehrslärm geplagten menschen im
rheintal und anderswo führen die
besucher die beschleunigung der
transeuropäischen schienenprojekte auch
innerhalb deutschlands ist sehr wichtig
ich blicke zu der fraktion der
bündnisgrünen schade dass der grüne
verkehrsminister von baden württemberg
das vom bund angebotene beschleunigte
verfahren zum ausbau der schienenwege in
seinem land abgelehnt hat vielleicht
können sie im hier noch etwas auf die
sprünge helfen
unabhängig davon geht es aber auch um
die frage des co2 neutralen bahnstroms
dieser liegt in deutschland bei 61
prozent
auch hier ist ein höheres ziel möglich
um eine wirklich nachhaltige
schieneninfrastruktur zu schaffen
ebenso will die eu eine deutliche co2
minderung in der industrie erreichen
ein wichtiges ziel doch diese lasten
müssen gerecht verteilt werden ohne
dabei industrie arbeitsplätze zu
gefährden
gerade die deutschen
automobilunternehmen mit ihren
zulieferern haben mit der umstellung auf
die abgasnorm euro 6 fiel vorbildhaftes
geleistet genau deswegen müssen wir nun
aufpassen bevor wir wieder neue
grenzwerte und somit neue kosten für
unsere wirtschaft aufbauen
krone hat uns doch gerade gelehrt wie
wichtig es ist industrielle produktion
in europa zu halten und nicht durch
zunehmende belastungen auf andere
kontinente zu verlagern
wir müssen die nachhaltige
transformation unserer industrie
gemeinsam mit den firmen und nicht gegen
sie gestalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nicht
ohne grund heißt das arbeitsprogramm
eine vitale union in einer fragilen welt
die aufnahme von corinna kreiler
patienten aus anderen eu-ländern in
eigenen krankenhäusern im übrigen eine
deutsche initiative ist ein gelungenes
beispiel dafür
die eu hat gezeigt dass sie bei aller
kritik in der lage ist in krisenzeiten
zu handeln solidarität zu zeigen und
dinge zu verändern
diesen mut müssen wir für künftige
herausforderungen bewahren dabei
nationalen egoismus bekämpfen
innereuropäischen grenzen wieder abbauen
und natürlich das arbeitsprogramm der
europäischen kommission konsequent
umsetzen
vielen dank
über christian rath das war ihre erste
regel im deutschen bundestag herzlich
wittmund station und auf gute
zusammenarbeit in diesem fall bekommt
der abgeordnete auch applaus wie das
hier üblich ist von allen fraktionen